hi thank you for hosting me today it's
my pleasure
my name is matt hat mahmud and i am
working as a
most talk fellow in cedlaczyk laboratory
i'm interested in comprehensive genomics
studying of structural variant
singularity variation and also building
software and the framework for
comprehensively understand
of variants today i shall present to you
princess princess is a framework for
comprehensive detection
and phasing of singing nucleotide
variant and structural variant
i will begin by give a brief
introduction
in general there is a lot of application
for sequencing i will mention a few of
them here
first of all medical application
including
identification of genomic causes of rare
diseases
understanding uh variant
in complex diseases characterization of
mutation
that
cause or drive cancer progression
for studying forensic analysis to have a
better understanding of
evolution drug discovery and
and eb genetics which is the study of
phenotype changes that does not include
inherited
sequence changes and lastly
for ecological studies
in the beginning we could classify
sequencing into three stages or three
main categories
first generation second and third
generation
for first generation i will give an
example here sanger one of the pioneer
sequencing the machinery of the tools
which were giving a high accuracy read
reaching up to one thousand bisbar this
was followed directory by second
generation sequencing i will give an
example here like an aluminum
second generation sequencing
revolutionize the idl sequencing
by performing barrel sequencing
which give a high throughput with high
accuracy data
and the reads with reaching around from
50 to 500 bits per
this was followed directly by third
generation gene sequencing
generation sequencing like back bio
and oxford nanopore the importance of
search generation sequencing
is that they were sequencing dna in real
time so
there is no amplification and the read
lens is
reaching on average 20 kb it of course
it may increase on that
as you can see from that the sequencing
itself also
could be classified into two categories
short reads
and long grades long reads added a lot
to the table
by enhancing genome assembly and
identification of structural variant
based on the increased grievance of the
risk
here i will give you an example tmt case
tmt is a gene that encodes the enzyme
that metabolizes
cyrobin drugs there is possibility that
two variant
could happen in the tmtg these variants
are 8 kb aboard if we can take a look to
the
down slide part to the sys part whether
there
are two blue bars let's say that this is
our
the genes in case of cis
we have this red bars which is a variant
having in one copy of the enzyme but the
other one
is working meaning now
we have one copy still working but the
other is not
so the patient is still able to
metabolize drugs if we take a look to
the
other bars that runs we can see that
this red variant
one happen in the first block
and the other in the second block
meaning what happened in the first
copy of the enzyme and the other
happening in the second copy
this means that the two copies of the
gene encoding the enzyme
is not working this will lead to the
accumulation of drugs
which is not helpful at all and could
lead to intoxication
as you can see from here
we need not only to study the variant
but also
if they are associated together or not
which called the block or facing
block based on that
we need if we are interested in sample
or disease
or an organism the first thing come to
our mind
is to study synchronicity variation as
in these for short
smds is a study the difference in on
nucleotide basis between
either two sample or one symbol and
reference
like as we can see here n1 and 2
there is a difference in where the arrow
is pointing between cg
and ta this is called snv or synchronous
type variant
the best tool or technology to study
this variant is illumina
nexus is to study structural variation
for short stb's suv is a kind of variant
that
different in size from smvs the size
ranges from
50 bits bare to more than that
for example here there is deletion
whereas abortion
of the sequence are deleted from the
sample compared to the reference
insertion where the new sequence was
inserted into the sample
again compared to the reference
duplication
abortion or part of the gene or the
sequence
is duplicated to have one or more copies
and version where the direction of the
sequence is self-inverted
the steady structural variant the best
tool we can use is
back bio or oxford nanoboard they give
us loan grids
which overcome the complexity of the
genomes and if the
structure variant is large we still can
detect it in an easy way
second step as we learned from the
previous slide is phasing
fizzing is the study of the coexistence
of variant together
for example here there are two groups of
variant
one marked with this green ball and the
other is the black bar
so we can see that the green variant are
having together in one block this blue
genomic region and the black variant
happening in the other block
to study phasing the best tools that we
could use at the moment is thin extra
genomics
last but not least is misrelation
resolution is adding of missile group in
cardboard number five that will not
change the the sequence
but could affect the expression to study
that we could use
illumina which is the best case
performance here or the
standard as you can see here we use
different library preparation
and different technology that will lead
to introduction of two kind of bias from
library preparation
and from the technology itself besides
that we need a larger amount of dna for
each library preparation
meanwhile we could avoid that by
using only long grid either it's oxford
nanopore
or backbone which will lead also to have
some in
the same information that we could
retrieve
but from that we the most important
point is we need to have a better
understanding to have a better
understanding
we need to improve the identification of
structured variant
and negative variant we need to improve
phasing
and we need to identify miscilation and
the most important
point is how they interact together
for such purpose i was inspired to
develop princess
princess is a framework for integrated
state-of-the-art tool
to study and analyze loan reads
so now the user has decided
to either go for bank buy or oxford
nervous and then you have his reads
first step of princess which will take
the reads as an input
it will give the user statistics about
the reads
like number afraid number of bases
n50 or the amount of freeze that he have
the longest shortest and so on and also
in this information
princess will implicitly choose and
optimize the barometer for each running
step
first step that princess will run is
mapping
and for mapping we're using either in
gmlr
or minimap and
again it will optimize the parameter for
each case and based on the library also
the next step after mapping is to
identify
single nuclear variation to identify
sinking repaired variant
we use clear clear is a successor of
clairvoyant
which is a neural network based program
to
call snlvs princess will choose the
optimal parameter
and the model to call a centerpiece
meanwhile or in barrel actually princess
will begin to start
calling structural variant using
sniffles
when the calling of the synergies or
singing thread variant
are done they add the second process
is a start which is phasing using
whatsapp and princess sub 2.
after phasing there is an optional step
if
the parental snips are available for the
user
it could be used to leverage the
identified and phased smvs
and identifies the hebrew type
for each snap another optional step
is the messylation using nanopolish
also it would be phase demisylation and
you typed
lastly this will be the full framework
beginning from the reads
to the in the output for each step
we will give the user quality matrix
statistics about what is happening in
that step
so we will have a better understanding
and bigger overview
and the end result will be two files the
first
is the variant file containing phase and
hablotype
structural variant and singularity
variant the second file is
the methylation also phased inhabitant
as we can see here princess
first its estimate parameter implicitly
it's run on cluster workstation and in
the cloud
the output file is simplified to three
files
the first is a single file for both smvs
and structure variant phase and header
type
the second file is also phased in hybrid
type installation
and the last file is the quality matrix
what we can see here that we manage to
identify single electric variant
we managed to identify structural
variant
we phased both snvs
and structural variant and were
identified and phased miscellation
using one library of regression by the
help of princess
now it's time for benchmarking we need
to benchmark the performance of princess
to do that we use the genome in a bottle
construction data
hcg002 here i will give you an overview
about the data that we used from left
to right first data is
back bio circular consensus read for
short ccs data ccs data
is high fidelity high accurate data
reaching around the 99 percent accuracy
the data that we used was of insert size
or
average rate length around 15 kp
the next data that we used is that bio
continuous
long grid for short clr it's another big
value but bio data
it's longer than ccs but it's of high
error rate reaching around
10 percent the average rate length that
we used here
was around 10 kb last
is oxford nanobore another long grid
technology we used here oxford nanoball
with average
size around 15 games
the next step is to
synchronic that variant benchmark for
that we also developed and
basically called in princess filtering
mechanism
to decrease false positive result this
filtering mechanism is implicitly
called by princess but the user also can
choose otherwise
we converted the results that we have
from
our filtering mechanism to the data of
gold standard
genomic bottle and we compared it using
rtg2
here is the result if we look to the
table
sorry it shows us the result of one flue
cell
for one flue cell the coverage for ccs
could roughly be around an x and for
back bio
clr and omt it would be 25 x
we managed to achieve a high precision
reaching around 99.5 percent in ccs data
and 97 and 92 for clr and
omnit respectively
if we look to the plot in the right hand
side
we convert increasing the coverage on
exercise
on the x axis from 5 to 95 x
with the f measure if measure is away
or as an equation to relate it to the
precision
and recall meaning the amount of the
truly identified
smv compared to the amount that we lost
or numbers that we misidentified
and the one that identified in the wrong
way as we can see clearly
by increasing the coverage we increase
the if measure so as clear we can
see with ccs data in red that we are
reaching around
97 or more for
only t and clr data in blue and green
we could reach also around 95.
we was not only interested in
benchmarking snvs
but we also benchmarked genotypes
genotype could be identified by four
ways
first clear itself it will give directly
genotype
the other one is whatsahab regenotype so
it takes the input from clear and region
types the data
and there are other two cases in phasing
what's have trust so it directly trusts
the input data and this trust it
does not trust the genotype data and
regional type
if we look here to the plot on the right
hand side we can see the comparison
between on the x-axis the missiles
that's used for genotype beginning
from clear what's have regional type and
what's have trust and distrust
and the percentage of correctness
that you could achieve you could clearly
see that clear achieved the highest
percentage of correctness reaching
around
99 in case of ccs data followed by
clr and oxoford nanoporting around 95.
based on this figure and the data that
we have we
managed to know that the best result is
directly from genotype from the clear
genotype
and in phasing we should use the phasing
first
data which gives the best result as you
can see here using what
have trust we reached accuracy of
97 percent of clr 99 percent in ccs
and 95 in oxford manipur
so now we bench market smvs and genotype
next is to benchmark structural variants
we use the gold the standard true set
from genomic bottle also
and we used to vary to compare what we
managed to achieve
was the true set
here here is the result
again for one flue cell we managed to
achieve a high precision
reaching 94 percent and ccs followed by
clr and oxford and oxford nebor 93 and
85 percent
and also managed to achieve a high
sensitivity
for the graph here we convert if we
increase the coverage
what we will resolve what will be the
result so we compress the coverage on
the x-axis
with the if measure on the y-axis
by increasing the result we could reach
to
uh more than 92 percent f measure in
case of ccs data
and for both oxford nanobore and clr we
also
managed to reach around 9192 percent of
f measure
the last thing that we want to benchmark
is phasing
here i will give you the examination of
the
phasing parameter that we will use to
benchmark phasing
i will begin with n50 on the left-hand
side
let's see that this says that we have a
chromosome
and this blue bar with the lens of 400
and we managed to identify
five blocks or five phasing blocks
ranging from size
of 150 to 40. we will sort
the phasing blocks from the longest to
the shortest
and we then calculate half length of the
chromosome
in our case it will be 200 we will begin
to add
these blocks one by one
till we reach greater than or equal to
hundred
so if we add 150 to 80 we will reach to
230 which is greater than 200
and the last block of the last shorter
bro
block that reached it to this amount was
80.
based on this information could see that
n50 is 80.
the second parameter is switching and
hamming error rate
let's say that we have two blocks a and
b
this is the true phasing and a is zeros
and b is one
what we predicted on the other hand we
could see that there is
here where the arrow is pointing a
switch error
this one should be in the b block note
in the a
this information we could see that we
have one switching error
that lead to four hamming errors these
ones
are for hamming errors so for phasing
benchmarking
we compare the coverage on the x-axis
from 5 to 95
and the first plot here is n50
and the y-axis is in 50 lengths it's
clearly from this graph that
oxford nanoborn in blue achieves the
highest in
50 over ccs and clr
but this was costing as you can see the
switch error rate
for x for nano bore was higher than ccs
and clr
but also we can see that overall
the switch error rate was less than
0.008
and by increasing the coverage we could
decrease the switch error rate
so which error rate as we saw from the
previous slide will lead to
a hamming error rate of course as
expected oxford nanoball will have the
highest hamming error rate
followed by clr and ccs as we can see
also
all of the three data set was less than
0.4
and if you look to the ccs and red it
nearly was zero because of the high
accuracy data
for one floor cell as we compared
earlier
comparing the n50 only as you can see
oxford nano bore
at the last row managed to achieve
around 17.4 megabits pair of n50
followed by clr and ccs with 15.15 and
point
12 make it display
another thing that we was interested in
benchmarking is
different ccs and search size i will
give you an introduction about what is
an insert size
answer starts for ccs data is if we look
to this
plot or this graph here we have the
smart built
in plate the green part is
the ligase sequence and this
cloud of grey is the enzyme the enzyme
will begin to move
in this arrow direction in a circle
in multiple circles with each circle he
will sequence
the insert size which is yellow and blue
let's say that
the enzyme will move only two times and
then full
so we will have the polymerase read as
you can see from the polymerase read
we have four star breeds because then
they moved only
two circles but normally it's more than
that of course
and then we will have the circular
consensus read or read of insert in the
black bar
know that the shorter the insert is
that will increase the number of round
that the enzyme moves
here we convert ccs of different insert
size
on the x axis 15
20 15 19 30 20 and 25
and the suv benchmarking was the
percentage on the y side
on the y axis comparing if measure in
red
precision in green and sensitivity in
blue
if we look to the upper part of the plot
here with the
overall performance we can see that the
overall the insert size does not affect
much
the f measure precision and recall of
the data
we are reaching around from 95 to 99
same for snb snv cooling without even
higher
if measure sensitivity and recall
for in the insertion deletion because of
the varying and size it was also varying
in if measure
and precision and recall
but there is an interesting thing here
to notice in the case of 25k
if we look to the overall and snips bar
we could see that
the difference between if measure
sensitivity and
cool and answer and call is
changing
that could be due to the large
larger insert size if you remember from
the previous slide
by increasing the third size we could
have or could lead to
lower number of rounds of the enzyme
which will decrease sensitivity a little
bit but overall
still over 95.
besides that also we compared the insert
size effect on the structural variant
as you can see here the difference was
really really narrow
the f measure was in red is
made you know roughly the same around 90
percent
with a higher precision
resistance already have been in use so
we use it in central of common disease
genomics or
ccdg for short and ccdg will
comprehensively identify rare risk and
the protective variant
we are focusing on cardiovascular
disease and neural
psychiatric disease we develop resources
informatic tools
and innovation approaches and which
approaches for
to reach the community
in ccdj data we used whole genome
sequencing and short treats but as you
know
short trees have its own limitation like
feeling of detecting some
smvs in certain region besides the
lag to detect some structural variant in
insertion
and complex duration here is an overview
of the project
we have around uh
we have we sequenced around 44 or more
than 44 thousand
symbols using short trades for whole
genome sequencing
to have a better understanding and to
dive deeper deeper
we need to use long reads but for this
amount of data it will be a little bit
impossible
what we did is to have an informative
symbol selection
based on the disease context of this
symbol so we can
be sequencing them longer so we selected
that
and we used longer reads and for long
reads we began to develop technologies
as
strategies and by blind so we have a
comprehensive understanding
and then we will validate the complex
variant we identify a novel structure
variant
will have phasing information and also
will build
an ethnicity variant catalog
here what we did we begin with short
read for whole genome sequencing we use
suv collector which optimally select
symbols that represents the cohort and
choose the different context of diseases
or the various causing diseases in the
cohort
after selecting sample we sequencing
them with long reads
then we use the principles for
comprehensive
detection of comprehensive understanding
of variant later we used
a graph to regenotype data and
we identified the new structured variant
and build the catalog
here is the real data that we used we
selected
11 samples from multiple ethnicity group
we're sequencing them in black value and
also we have rna-seq for them
versus was around on it was run in this
data to have
a variant diction for all of synovias
and structural variants
and we identified and phased impeccable
structural variant and we studied
how the invectives are in easy
for just an example i will give here
hlab hlb is play an important or crucial
role
in the immune system here by using
princess
there is a comparison between two
samples the upper one whereas there is
a homozygote structural variant
and on the lower sample in green there
is a heterozygote structural variant
we compare that to the exhibition we
could clearly
see the difference between the
homozygous and the heterozygous variant
on the rna-seq expression overall
in conclusion princess could use long
breed either from oxford nanobar
or from back bio and
will give the current information it
will map the read using engine and
r or minimap it will identify single
nucleotide variant using
cloud it will identify structural
variant
both smvs and destruction variant it
could extend phasing
and leverage information using parental
snip's information
it will identify and phase the solution
and it will give you a quality statistic
for each step
so it is one step for all of these
analysis using just one liability
preparation
process is already available and beta
version
on github so i will be more than happy
if you give it a try and
i would like to learn or to hear from
you about the feedback
about my ongoing and current or future
work actually
i'm trying to expand the qc statistics
benchmark visualization and currently
i'm developing another
part of princess called the high
fidelity option
if you remember from the first slide
long reads like clr
and oxford nanobar have a higher error
rate reaching around 9 to 10 percent
from the data we have we have the bam
file
and we have information about the have
low time
in this workflow i will try to extract
the hablotype information or the reads
from the bam file
and then use self correction to have a
high fidelity
hablotyped breeds then i will align them
and after aligning them again i will
identify the snvs
and structural variant this will lead to
a high fidelity identified phased
and hablotype snvs and the structural
variant
at the end of my talk i would like to
thank human genome sequencing center
especially
princeton logic harsha and richard gibbs
and of course our host and our audience
thank you